Speaker 1: Hey, this is really good
news. Democrats have unveiled a bill
proposing full decriminalization of drug
possession, as well as expunging the records of
many who have already been convicted along those
lines. And we've been talking about this for a
very long time. We have talked about the racist
origins of the war on drugs, which I will get to
in a moment. We've talked about a lot of
other issues related to this, including
the way that police departments defend unenforced,
depend on sorry, depend on enforcing many of these
laws in order to sustain themselves financially.
We've talked about private prisons. We've talked
about all of these different things. And then
there was a question, well, what are we going to
see from Democrats under Joe Biden along these
lines? And we have now learned that there is a
really comprehensive bill that has been proposed.
So let's go through it. Newsweek reporting
a bill to end criminal penalties for drug
possession at the federal level was unveiled by
Democrats Tuesday yesterday ahead of the fiftieth
anniversary of President Richard Nixon declaring
the war on drugs, the Drug Policy Reform Act
would decriminalize personal use, possession of
all scheduled drugs, including marijuana, heroin
and cocaine, and automatically expunge records
and provide for resentencing for those serving
time for certain drug related arrests. Now,
I know many people will say, David, this isn't
this isn't perfect. We need legalization instead
of decriminalization and we need to expunge all
we're talking about major progress. If this were
to pass, it's already a major step forward. There
would still be more to do. But let's actually go
let's take these steps. It would also
prohibit the denial of employment,
immigration status, public benefits, voting
rights and more based upon criminal history
for drug possession. The legislation proposed
by Representatives Corey Bush of Missouri
and Bonnie Watson Coleman of New Jersey, also
called for the country to address substance abuse
with more health centered approaches. Very, very
important. June 17th will mark 50 years since
Nixon designated drugs as, quote, America's
public enemy number one. Can you imagine?
Since then, drug offenses have become the leading
cause of arrests in the US. According to the Drug
Policy Alliance, in twenty nineteen, more than one
point five million arrests were made due to drug
violations under the DPRK. Authority and criteria
for the classification of substances would shift
from the U.S. attorney general to the Secretary of
Health and Human Services. This could be a really
big deal in terms of actual rescheduling. It's
not just about decriminalization, it's also about
rescheduling of drugs. Importantly, the bill would
also direct the HHS to establish a grant program
supporting initiatives that expand access to
substance abuse treatment. This is really simple,
guys. This is we should treat this issue like
a public health issue, not a criminal issue.
And if you go back to the origins of the war on
drugs and then you look at the genesis and the
catalysts that led to it, you end up understanding
also, by the way, if you go back even further to
prohibition of alcohol. Early in the 20th century,
the enforcement of the prohibition of these drugs
may well lead to more crime than it prevents.
I don't think it's exaggerated to say that. And
you would have thought maybe we learned that
during alcohol prohibition in the United States,
there were decades between that and Nixon
launching the war on drugs. So maybe it was
just too long. The war on drugs also justifies
police departments asking for a ton of money
to fight drugs. When you task police departments
with with fighting, you know, possession of drugs.
The idea of fighting that criminally is
crazy. But when you task them with that,
they can justify significantly larger budgets.
So while I am not a defund the police scheme,
I'm a reform and fix the police guy. One of
the the really interesting things about this
is that the war on drugs justifies higher funding
levels for police and then the need to root out
drug possession is used as a reason to erode
privacy rights, public safety across the board.
Listen, we've got to be if we're police and we
need to fight drug possession as a criminal issue,
we should be monitoring phone calls related to
drug deals. We need to be moderate monitoring and
surveilling the Internet for drug deals. We need
to be able to search houses on suspicion of drugs.
We shot him because he had drugs or we suspected
that he had drugs or plan to sell them. How many
times have we heard that? And when you go back
to the genesis of this, the war on drugs was
created partially in response to the direction
that civil rights were. We're going and had
gone in the United States, starting with the
civil rights movement, late 50s into the 60s.
The idea was we need a different way. This was
the right saying we need a different way to
control so-called undesirable populations and to
be able to when we want to, when we need to deny
certain populations of rights. And this is not an
unfortunate side effect of the drug war, which was
otherwise well intentioned. This was the point.
It's a feature and not a bug. And in 1994, John
Erlichman said to Harper's journalist Dan Bohm,
quote, The Nixon campaign in 68 and the White
House after that had two enemies, the antiwar left
and black people. You understand what I'm saying?
We knew we couldn't make it illegal to be either
against the war or black. But by getting the
public to associate the hippies with marijuana and
blacks with heroin and then criminalizing both, we
could disrupt those communities. We could arrest
their leaders, we could raid their homes. We
could break up their meetings, vilify them night
after night. On the evening news, did we know we
were lying about the drugs? He asked. Of course we
did. There's no question about the origins of this
step one. And this is it's really just step one of
many is we need full decriminalization. We need to
expunge as many of those records as possible.
Democrats have proposed it, proposed it. We'll
talk later in the week or early next about what
is the chance that this really moves forward and
becomes law. But let me know your thoughts. How
significant do you think this would be? I think
it would be extraordinarily significant. If you
disagree or you agree, let me know. You can find
me on Twitter at David Pakman. My friends, please
don't forget that The David Pakman Show is an
independent media program, it's just us, we have
no big corporate funders or overlords or a money
tree in the backyard. It's just us. So we
depend on you to fund the show. You can help us
in achieving that most simply by getting a
membership at Join Pakman Dotcom. You get access
to a daily extra show just for you, just for our
members. When you sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom,